hello guys friday of course it's a
torture chamber time I apologize to you
guys for my anime but that was done by
my good friend Julio another producer
here at gamespot but it was fun anyways
we're going to be playing Erie's action
today as you can see on the screen it
looks cute but I have this feeling I'm
not going to have a fun cute time
anyways here we go all right Oh what the
hell is that right off the bat I don't
even know what that thing was is that
like a bath pan guide to this theory to
the stage goal alright I get to a flag
checkpoint alright alright Spike's right
off the bat all right let's try run jump
all right crisis averted
oh do I need those hmm
is the water is the water safe let's
find out okay like what are those plant
eaters I think it like I think they ate
my clothes
oh no what is that minecraft guy give me
a loan okay okay oops oh you can pick
stuff up
Oh bouncy okay
you
oh you're an idiot I'm just gonna wait
I'm gonna wait man what's up with his
voice yeah I have a high pitched voice
you should have saw it in her you should
have heard it not saw it hurted in high
school it was actually worse I think one
of my one of my good friends mom oh come
on cat Mario status right there but back
to the story one of my friend's mom's
actually called me Mickey Mouse in high
school that's how bad it was what's the
what's the help market ear you can enter
basis by pressing down while on top of
the vase it teleports her to wear let's
find out usually usually in these stupid
games when you teleport bad things
happen so you know what could possibly
go wrong when i teleport Jesse what you
don't know why I don't know why I don't
listen to myself I don't also you guys
want to know right so we have to find
out oh the wind meal really ok the
windmills falls on me so I am supposed
to jump past it awesome ok Oh what are
you kidding me the wind meal followed me
and trapped me with a box oh I see what
dirty game you're playing at I don't
appreciate it who is it ok
right I what I was thinking I was
thinking I'm scared Oh screw you okay
reactions baby yeah Oh what is that how
am I supposed to know these gray weeds
would kill me are you a friend are you a
friend nope not a friend oh he moves I
activated him wonder if I needed that
hahaha troll boxes everywhere it follows
me stop it stop following me go back
this way no okay what is that guy Oh a
frog hot spring oh you can't even kill
that guy oh there's a save point yes no
just pick this bomb up I killed the goal
okay
do I win I died
that's not even as far as I wanted to be
all the second son of a bee Oh does this
work that that seem like that would work
no take me over I barely touched the tip
of the top of the flag all right all
right yeah success this has to be it
right we did it to the next world how
many more worlds are there I really Oh
am I supposed to move back I can't
believe there's one that is so troll I'm
gonna go jump block the block do we do
we dare to find out oh the third one was
a freaking plane eater we're going in
we're going in ah no off why do I even
go the vases why Oh does this guy is
this guy a friendly are you friendly
you're like my boyfriend I kill you oh
no you try to throw me into the spikes f
you mr. guy Oh what is this no no just
go with the flow oh do I dare to go up
right Oh
it clips through the freaking ground
gotten both fakeblock achievement
unlocked thank you thank you that's the
best chivo right there Oh dollars and
others there's another one come please
please no oh my god or maybe the chicken
can be my buffer nope yes
spring the trap do it I'll stock you
from behind Oh what is it ok that's ok
that's ok we'll just pick them up yeah
oh ok ok you set the traps off yeah ok
yes I don't trust this platform I don't
trust this platform one bit quick jump
okay okay bouncy mushroom oh I'm dead
did you see me fly oh my god twinkle
twinkle dear plant ladder please work
nope you da god damn it twinkle twinkle
me do anything oh legit mushroom hiding
[ __ ] jerks I'm gonna sue my can't all
oh whoa it's got glue on the box she was
stuck okay we're not touching that box
oh you [ __ ] you [ __ ] why are you
even over there but how do I oh maybe
this one
oh no no oh what's up okay I need to
throw it where that guy's going to throw
the spike oh that's so close come on
ditch it yeah suck on that very good
that success please don't troll me yeah
yeah yeah ok this is the boss oh no it's
bowser wah ha ha ha hey girl sorry why
won't let you pass oh I get past me
you'll have to beat me first guy that's
a lot of life ok pick those up ok can I
can I jump on your head just come on
stupid ball on that oh oh I'm still
alive ok don't know how that worked oh
you dirty you can so how do I avoid the
lower ones too cool suck on that oh no
what is it
yeah suck on what side are you gonna be
on okay what's what's this one Oh God oh
I got lucky oh my god can you actually
get behind him that actually would be
pretty sick if you could go behind him
okay oh my god hacks hey dude hey what's
up what's up man suck on that oh it's
like that please be dead yeah yeah don't
troll me don't troll me Oh karate kid
okay Scott you a little swimming do I
want that diamond I want that diamond oh
good this game the diamonds are never
what you want I'm gonna assume the fish
kill me fished I got me I here we can't
touch these dis a blue reef stuff I'm
scared to press his button I really am
okay I'm gonna go right Oh God can I
turn it back off I made the thing go
faster there's a flag there anything for
the flag please don't troll me though
game you don't want oh that was dirty I
got really lucky there ah see you always
gotta always be on your a-game nothing
is safe why why why it it automatically
it automatically just sucks me down
there oh that was complete [ __ ] that
I got past there I just you mean fish
like right swim swim harder
just just yes oh man we didn't get
head-butted okay what bad things gonna
happen here it ok it doesn't look like
it but it sucked me to the wall ok I
don't want yes ok ok no no I'm okay come
on oh my god no no no no no I ok my
spider-sense says there's something bad
that's going to happen here I don't know
what it is though cus Mike's got spikes
for me yeah yup get out of here with
that get at it why did you come back
Kermit Kermit why go go before he comes
back oh thank god freaking Kermit the
Frog man why I died and put back in the
vase I can't go back in the base
I'm just dead sweet I got abducted by
kermit the frog and his friends go just
run see what's up we did that exact same
thing last time how did I how did I die
oh right off the bat huh right off the
bat I'm trying to talk to twitch chat
did you just see what that stupid bird
did did you see what he just did to my
blocks he took them away from me that
[ __ ] I'm scared of this emerald thing
ok are you serious there's no more
platforms on the Left coming what I'm
pretty sure I needed the platform then
yeah thank you guys for watching hit the
follow button if you're not already
following a gamespot switch so you guys
know when we're streaming like we said
we're going to start streaming more
often so you know stay tuned to that I
thank you guys again hash huh Wow three
o'clock today that's right the game
gamespot gameplay podcast will be live
so stay tuned for that that's in about
an hour hashtag Diaz torture if you guys
have any suggestions right now I'm
leaning towards the impossible quiz
possibly next week it's not as gamey but
it's kind of trollee fun so we'll see
but yeah put it in the comments or tweet
at me either way thanks see you guys
later have a good friday weekend see you
guys at three